la la nostra
la civiltà tecnologica si basa su degli
strumenti questi sono quelli che abbiamo
iniziato a sviluppare
millenni fa erano pietre erano martelli
armi erano oggetti fisici inizialmente e
questi si sono evoluti ci hanno
consentito di essere più veloci dove
magari eravamo lenti di essere
più forti dove ci mancava la forza
si può dire che tutto quello che abbiamo
adesso grazie a questi strumenti che
abbiamo potuto inventare questi nel
diciamo
in fondo ci hanno consentito di vivere
meglio la quello che
vorremmo è che migliorassero sempre modo
da supportare la nostra qualità della
vita
vorremmo che questo trend continuasse
magari che fosse continua maniera
esponenziale
il motivo per cui questo è successo
lo dobbiamo in fondo al nostro cervello
proprio ultimamente ho di recente se
volete negli ultimi 15 anni sono
individuate anche le aree del nostro
cervello che
controllano l'uso degli strumenti
oppure li riconoscono pure capiscono la
loro funzione tutto questo è molto
importante perché poi su questi
strumenti appunto abbiamo basato la
nostra tecnologia
una cosa che vorremmo
è che questi strumenti
fossero fisici molti lo sono già se uso
martello certamente uno strumento fisico
ma lo devo usare io
altri strumenti
sono un po meno fisici il calcolatore
uno di questi è certamente posso fare
delle cose e certamente lo dei risultati
ma in quanto ad agire nel mondo il
calcolatore non fa tantissimo il quello
che ci serve è dotare la tecnologia
dell'informazione di un corpo come
indicato in questo in questa immagine
l'idea è che io possa chiedere ai miei
strumenti di fare qualcosa se io oggi
chiedo al mio smartphone di fare
qualcosa il qualcosa intangibile
modifica dell'informazione cambia
qualcosa ma a meno che non c'è alla fine
qualcuno che agisca per me non riescono
a muovere degli oggetti per esempio
invece quello che ci piacerebbe fare e
che questa tecnologia dell'informazione
si connetta al mondo reale al mondo
fisico
questo è stato illustrato tante volte
nel cinema nel film
la robotica si è vista spesso diciamo in
vesti più o meno carine io qui ho preso
solo le vesti carine quelle più
simpatiche per cui la possibilità di
avere
l'inserviente robotizzato piuttosto che
l'aiutante piuttosto che il compagno
piuttosto che
diciamo robot che aiuta la persona è un
po più debole in questo caso ci ha
indicato un film recente abbastanza
conosciuto dove il robot aiutava appunto
un signore anziano
questo ovviamente il cinema e il film
noi vorremmo che questa cosa in qualche
modo si connettesse alla realtà di nuovo
quindi da un certo punto di vista
abbiamo la tecnologia delle informazioni
che si connette al mondo fisico è un
altro punto di vista la fantasia ci
siamo sempre immaginati queste cose
vorremmo che anche queste si
commettessero alla realtà
come si può fare come vorremmo farlo è
la nostra scommessa è che questa cosa si
possa fare con la robotica con un tipo
particolare di robotica che ha sembianze
umanoidi e questo è quello che è e
indicato qui questo non è un film
questa foto che vedete qua non è preso
da nessun film e quello che facciamo
tutti i giorni quindi questa è la nostra
ricerca nel campo della robotica
umanoide il vorremmo appunto dare un
corpo alla tecnologia dell'informazione
immaginate poter avere una macchina a
cui chiedete banalmente di portarvi il
caffè di trovare delle cose per voi però
di farlo per davvero
non è come il cellulare io adesso posso
andare dal mio smartphone e chiedere chi
è il presidente del consiglio italiano e
lui risponde esiste un'app per android
per esempio mi risponde mi dice chi è mi
trova una pagina web
compare la pagina con la biografia con
tutte le informazioni connesse alla
domanda che ho chiesto e questo è
fattibile però se io chiedo il mio
smartphone di portare un caffè non c'è
verso ora vorremmo che invece questo
diventasse possibile poi questo è
ovviamente un esempio evento un esempio
banale ma immaginate le applicazioni se
potessimo cambiare i nostri dispositivi
in questo modo
potrei averlo detto io voi che dite ma
insomma giorgio meta un pazzo è venuto
qui a raccontarci ste cose però ci sono
degli altri signori che hanno detto così
simili uno sicuramente bill gates nel
2008 scritto un articolo per santifica
american dove diceva appunto
che il mondo sarebbe molto interessante
se si riuscisse a mettere un robot in
ogni casa cosa voleva dire lui che
siamo probabilmente all'inizio di una
tecnologia che potrebbe in effetti
essere messa in ogni casa questo signore
faceva nel caso l'esempio il confronto
con la tecnologia dell'informazione
degli inizi quando lui scrive dai primi
sistemi operativi probabilmente comunque
con la situazione adesso della robotica
siamo comunque all'inizi ancora della
strada da fare ma le potenzialità ci
sono tutte
il
come conclusione di questo articolo lui
diceva anche che una eventuale ditta che
vendesse robot che potrebbero essere
utilizzati in ogni caso diventerebbe
sicuramente molto più grande come
dimensione come non so fatturato
qualunque cosa di microsoft stessa
perché avrebbe qualcosina in più e
questo qualcosina sarebbe la connessione
col mondo fisico col mondo reale
questo è un altro signore che dice cose
simili si chiama aaron brooks è il
signore che vi ha messo in casa il
roomba se non se non l'avete però sapete
cos'è almeno
diciamo un primo robot di successo con
distribuzione consumer quindi con
qualcosa che mi è andato al di là di dei
pochi esemplari costruiti
adesso questo signore si è imbarcato
un'altra avventura ha lasciato ai robot
compagni che faceva il rombo e si è
messo a fare qualcos'altro che sono dei
robot più o meno umanoidi per
l'industria sono dei robot due braccia
con delle pinze un po particolari e
hanno la bellezza se volete di essere
programmabili in maniera semplice lui ha
preso veramente gli operatori quelli
della catena di montaggio egli ha detto
vi do questo robot vuoi in dieci minuti
lo programmate gli fate fare il vostro
compito e voi state lì a guardare questa
qui era un po l'idea del diciamo di
questo nuovo progetto credo che sia
tutto sommato interessante poi lui dice
anche ma insomma il cielo il malaugurio
vedono sempre male adesso dicono che io
tolgo e posti di lavoro in realtà lui
quello che dice i task e ripetitivi non
sono divertenti per nessuno se ce ne
liberiamo forse meglio
dopodiché le persone diventeranno magari
i programmatori di questi nuovi robot
quindi diciamo la nostra esperienza la
nostra bravura sarà non tanto nel
ripetere delle azioni a mano magari
mettere le cose dentro le scatole ma
esisterà un robot che fa lo stesso
lavoro io devo programmarlo di giorno in
giorno potrà cambiare leggermente il
compito e io potrò sempre essere la
persona che in realtà programma il robot
ci sono degli altri signori ancora in
questo caso interviene se volete le
istituzioni o la politica che dicono che
dovremmo fare queste cose
in particolare la commissione europea ha
identificato una serie di obiettivi se
volete per il prossimo programma quadro
alcuni di questi che vedete qua sono
potenzialmente
attaccabili se volete comunque la
robotica può fare una parte da leone
all'interno di questi di questi
obiettivi uno è contrastare o in qualche
modo far fronte al fatto che la
popolazione invecchia progressivamente
nei prossimi da qui al 2020 il numero di
anziani sarà salito del doppio rispetto
ad esso i numeri sono più o meno a
questi qui
la è necessario essere comunque
produttivi in maniera sostenibile e per
questo l'automazione può fare di nuovo
una parte molto importante
ci sono problemi come il riscaldamento
globale che possono essere
sicuramente
non risolti ma monitorati attraverso
soluzioni robotiche esistono dei robot
per il monitoraggio ambientale questi
potrebbero appunto fare di nuovo a
ricoprire un ruolo importante e poi
nella sicurezza tutti si ricordano del
disastro nel golfo del messico piuttosto
che fukushima
quindi anche in quel campo avere dei
robot potrebbe diventare una soluzione
per il futuro quindi vedete ci sono vari
se volete predicatori c'è stato bill
gates è stato brooks le istituzioni
stanno dicendo la stessa cosa quindi
s'ha da fare
in
particolare vorrei adesso dirvi che cosa
dobbiamo fare perché insomma è bello
dire facciamo di robot ma poi bisogna
farli per davvero
questo è quello che abbiamo fatto noi e
questa la ricerca che stiamo portando
avanti è un robot umanoide come avete
visto delle foto prima
diciamo prima che iniziassimo il
progetto non esisteva questo qui l'anno
prossimo facciamo dieci anni di vita
dietro a questo oggetto qui il
diciamo la particolarità se volete del
progetto che è completamente open source
per cui in teoria chiunque lo può
copiare e riutilizzare pratica non è
tanto semplice copiarlo rifarlo anche se
prete disegni non li potete costruire in
cantina però in linea teorica potete
guardare come fatto il software potete
guardare le soluzioni che abbiamo
adottato noi e questo dà una mano a
costruire una comunità della ricerca
quindi quei pallini che adesso vedete
nella mappa del mondo sono posti dove
abbiamo il nostro robot come vedete
l'europa è stato facile ce ne sono tanti
ma questo anche grazie al supporto della
ue della commissione europea del fatto
che i colleghi ci conoscono meglio però
vedete che c'è anche un pallino sul
giappone questo non è male per essere un
robot italiano perché andare a mettere
un robot umanoide in giappone tutto
sommato motivo di orgoglio quindi per
una volta possiamo dire che abbiamo
esportato qualcosa ce ne sarà un altro
in corea l'anno prossimo che già
indicato perché è in fase di costruzione
e ce n'è uno anche negli stati uniti gli
stati uniti sono un po più ostici da
questo punto di vista perché le cose che
non so fabbricate lì si fa un po più di
fatica a venderle il
diciamo andata talmente bene che l'anno
scorso ci hanno anche confuso per
tedeschi diceva in qualche modo
esisteva questa foto del di angela
merkel con il nostro robot durante un
evento è il financial times parlando
della germania diceva scritto un
articolo che si intitolava la macchina
miracolosa e hanno messo ovviamente una
macchina e un robot umanoide in questo
caso
in qualche modo hanno connesso alle due
cose va peccato che roboto fosse
italiano meno male che il corriere della
sera l'ha visto e ha fatto un altro
articolo dicendo bene fa elogiano la
germania benissimo l'economia tedesca va
benissimo però robot non ce l'ha non era
tedesco quindi tutto sommato un motivo
di soddisfazione
il robot è anche apparso in una serie di
riviste
badate bene quest'anno le scienza sono
solo cose giornalisti che però tutto
sommato fa piacere vedere che il
pubblico è interessato a vedere come sta
andando la robotica il
questo video vi faccio anche vedere un
pochino cosa fa robot
diciamo un video che una composizione di
tante piccole cose ma da un'idea delle
capacità per esempio da un'idea del
fatto che robot abbia degli occhi per
vedere del alle mani molto sofisticate
questo si connette a quello che dicevo
all'inizio sull'utilizzo degli strumenti
se dobbiamo avere degli strumenti ci
vogliono le mani poi per poterli
utilizzare questo robot ha le mani cosa
diversa da quello che si trova di solito
in commercio
vedete che può vedere le cose gli si può
chiedere di indicare delle cose per cui
riconoscere gli oggetti che si trova
davanti per cui qui ad esempio gli si
chiede ma qual è la pallina rossa tra
tutte le cose che trovi sul tavolo e lui
la punta il
diciamo è questo qui è una serie di
potenziali funzioni può toccare le cose
gli si può chiedere di prenderle besson
nella prossima sequenza si vede che
afferra un oggetto
questo qui
è un inizio per avere uno strumento che
vi fa il caffè tutto sommato questo qui
è l'oggetto che vi serve per andare a
prendere prende il caffè prendi la
tazzina metti questo qua sistema insomma
potete immaginare lì cosa può fare qui
un esempio dove robot riguarda qualcosa
e acquisisce informazioni sulla forma
sulla consistenza di un oggetto
per ora sono solo giocattoli ma si può
fare facilmente la modifica per
utilizzare altre cose e questa è una
cosa altra un'altra cosa simpatica dove
il robot viene insegnato nazione nuova
questa è una cosa che il robot non aveva
mai visto
rovesciare qualcosa dentro un
contenitore e gli viene insegnato
semplicemente prendendolo muovendo lungo
una certa traiettoria lui memorizza
sente quanta forza è stata fatta
memorizza la traiettoria in grado di
ripeterla per portare a compimento un
certo diciamo certo tasca
bene un ulteriore elemento per poter
fare queste cose e avere il supporto del
del centro di ricerca delle istituzioni
dello stato
per cui qui volevo
raccontare che è necessario fare anche
dell'altro bisogna investire in ricerca
tutto sommato è abbastanza scontato da
dire lo dicono in tanti ma poi farlo è
complicato soprattutto poi magari in
periodi di crisi economica però cosa qui
è la ricerca che poi vi consentirà di
avere il caffè a letto senza doverlo
chiedere a nessuno
chiedendolo robot
vengo da un posto che si chiama
l'istituto italiano di tecnologia il
quartier generale a genova ma in realtà
con possano network che sono sparsi in
tutta italia
abbiamo un piano scientifico quindi
abbiamo una linea guida che ci dice cosa
fare tra le cose che dobbiamo fare cioè
la robotica ma non solo robotica da sola
magari sarebbe un po riduttivo ma noi
abbiamo delle connessioni ad esempio cui
nero scienziati che ci dicono come il
cervello risolvere certi compiti e
chissà che alcune delle soluzioni che
noi implementiamo nel robot è in realtà
siano derivate dalle cose che ci dicono
i neuroscienziati
neuroscienziati a loro volta si
connettono con un altro gruppo di
persone che studiano le molecole che
sono in grado di agire dentro il
cervello quindi sviluppano anche nuovi
farmaci
gli sviluppatori di nuovi farmaci
sfruttano le tecnologie che sono
in qualche modo costruite da un altro
gruppo di persone che si occupano di dei
cosiddetti smart materials quindi da
materiali nanostrutturati che aiutano
vuoi a capire come fare certe molecole
vuoi a visualizzarle vuoi a costruirne
di nuove e poi eventualmente a provarle
il
smart materials si connettono anche però
con aspetti di energia quindi ci danno
la possibilità di costruire per esempio
batterie più efficienti o sistemi di
produzione dell'energia più efficienti e
questi tornano buoni per la robotica
perché se devo fare il robot che va in
giro per la casa ho bisogno che il robot
sia autonomo indipendente
il piano scientifico si ispira
tantissimo anche alla natura equa
vediamo un esempio di come i vari
livelli alle varie scale dal umanoide
alla molecola in realtà si connettono
comunque hanno un parallelo nella natura
diciamola un posto dove abbiamo
scienziati da tutto il mondo 50 paesi
diversi
l'età media anche se non la potete
vedere da queste foto in realtà è di
circa 34 anni quindi un posto di
giovanissimi io sono un po più vecchio
purtroppo ma è un posto interessante e
questi sono alcuni dei risultati che
abbiamo
diciamo portato a termine di recente se
volete qua si vedono un po di video dove
facciamo vedere l'evoluzione della
camminata dal gattonare e qualche volta
anche con qualche fallimento come potete
vedere in questo video
al tirarsi in piedi
al fare qualche passo
aiutato da una persona e poi in fondo a
fare qualche passo invece in maniera
autonoma se volete questo qui è un po il
progresso delle cose che stiamo facendo
il diciamo ed è un pezzettino di quello
che ci serve per arrivare al famoso
caffè che vi dicevo all'inizio e con
questo vi ringrazio